all right now the latest on a family
that lost a child in the sandy hook
massacre trying to rebuild their lives
and to punish the man they accused of
spreading lies and causing chaos for
them talk radio host alex jones has
repeatedly given air time to claims that
the 2012 school shooting in newtown
connecticut was staged by the government
those were quotes the parents of
six-year-old jesse lewis are suing him
for 150 million dollars as janet
chameleon reports jones and the boy's
parents came face to face yesterday
during heart-wrenching testimony in an
austin texas courtroom
i can't even describe
the last nine and a half years of the
living hell
that i and others have had endure
because of the negligence and the
recklessness of alex jones neil heslin
and scarlett lewis the parents of jesse
lewis addressed the court tuesday in
their lawsuit against alex jones
heslin and lewis say they live in fear
after receiving death threats unwelcome
emails and phone calls as a result of
jones lies my home was shot out
vehicles were shot up in my yard jones
who was noticeably absent for heslin's
testimony was recording his podcast
continuing to attack the parents i think
it's a disrespect
and i think it is cowardly active alex
jones not to be facing me here in this
courtroom jones appeared in court later
tuesday i don't think that you
understand the repercussions
of
going on air with a huge audience and
lying
shaking his head as lewis spoke to him
directly jesse was real i am a real mom
i know you know that that's the problem
i know you know that and you keep saying
it
you keep saying it
why the judge appearing to grow
frustrated with jones's attitude during
the hearing i remember currently stopped
remember day one where i said
it's an unfair world and you don't get
to interrupt the judge
jones attempted to speak with the
parents after taking the stand shaking
hands with them an attorney for the
family quickly ended the interaction
exchanging words with jones on the way
out of the courtroom that's not even a
thought that's not the way this goes
jones outside court continued to say the
families were being manipulated
for lewis and heslin their son's life
and death was very real he did live
i was blessed with six and a half years
he's been going one and a half times
and i cherish those days
those years
for cbs mornings janet shamley in
houston
i'm speechless
there are no words there are no words
you know um one of the parents said
it's like losing a limb
like i know it's supposed to be there
but it's not there my heart just goes
out to those families who after all
these years are still suffering and are
still in pain and are still going
through this trauma and the recklessness
of the words of someone that can spew
those things about families that are
dealing with so much trauma every day
yeah for the rest of their lives live
with it for the rest of their lives nate
absolutely right it's terrible